says it stands now the CCP owns around
two billion dollars worth of American
land but our next guest is also vowing
to crack down on China's land grab and
like Governor young and she is leading
the way in the great state of South
Dakota we have Governor Christie gnome
as well as Governor good to see you
first of all
I you were a Pioneer you were the first
governor I believe in the country to say
no to tick tock because our Intel
Community have been saying it's being
used as a spying mechanism against
Americans I'll give you credit for that
now you're one of the first to say no to
the Chinese buying up Farmland Ranch
Land and land near military
installations I give you credit for that
tell us how you came to those decisions
well we've also I've done an executive
order that has said that we won't do
state contracts and telecommunications
companies will not do business in South
Dakota that affiliate themselves with
China as well so we've been aggressive
on fighting this threat that president
of Biden will not address I've got a
bill I'm working with a couple of
legislators in South Dakota to ban China
from being able to buy up our Farmland
agriculture is our number one industry
in our state but we also are the home of
Ellsworth Air Force Base Ellsworth is
going to be the home of the b-21s the
Next Generation bombers that will
protect the United States of America for
many many years to come and China would
love to set up shop next door and
conduct surveillance on that platform
and we won't allow it we'll make sure
that our land stays under the United
States control and that we won't allow
enemies that hate us to come in and to
purchase our assets I've been in food
security policy for many many years over
20 years I've seen China buy up our
third
companies are chemical companies they've
bought up our processing systems now
they're buying our land and they're
doing it to destroy us and it's time we
get a president that wises up loves this
country defends us and stops acting like
a dimwit in front of the whole world
I think that pretty much sums it up
Governor
I want to ask you about the issues with
the balloon and I don't know which part
is worse for me the fact that they
allowed the Communist Chinese to have
their spy balloon go from Alaska to
Idaho to Montana and all around the
country before they finally shot it down
off the coast of the Carolinas or Joe
Biden going out there today saying he
had no earthly clue what the other three
objects were that he ordered our
military to shoot down with four hundred
thousand dollar Sidewinder missiles now
I don't know what's worse or are they
equally as bad what are your thoughts
uh all equally as bad it's unbelievable
to me they don't know what these objects
are yet Sean let me tell you a story I
was standing upstairs in the governor's
residence actually in my closet when one
of my staffers came upstairs and said
Governor we need to talk to you
downstairs about a national security
issue that you need to be briefed on by
your National Guard they indicated to me
that the Pentagon and Department of
Defense had reached out to them that
they needed to be on alert because there
was a foreign object in the sky over
Montana that would be coming into South
Dakota the next 24 hours and our assets
might need to be utilized to take it
down now listen Sean this was two days
before the rest of the country even knew
that this object existed and the
Pentagon in the White House did not let
me know as governor of South Dakota that
my National Guard may be utilized that
my f-16s or my Personnel that have
expertise and recovery of these kind of
objects might be tapped to come in and
assist the United States and they did
not have any communication with me until
the balloon had already crossed through
South Dakota when was over the central
United States in fact when you guys were
reporting on Fox news that it was over
Montana that balloon had already crossed
into the middle of the country so this
is the kind of deception that we have
going on with our Administration this is
what they've lied to the American people
covered it up they've gone around
Governors and not communicated to us and
frankly I believe they shot this balloon
down over the water because they wanted
to be able to decide what was on board
that balloon and if some of it was lost
at sea that they didn't want us to ever
know about that was an easy narrative
that they could sell to us that they
could keep as much quiet as they felt
they wanted to I would have loved to
have seen them retrieve it in full and
take it down to earth we can send men to
the to the moon and land and the moon
and walk around and get back on that
ship and come back home I would think
they'd be able to pull that off last
question Governor are you come
contemplating at all Run for the
presidency
no not today
we've got a lot of
a lot of focus on but that seems
we appreciate you being with us as
always thank you